- Ja'Marr Chase, Jaylen Waddle, DeVonta Smith. I'll remember
everyone who's in front of me.
- Bro, we're in a line. It's the Quarter-Season Carnival.
- Men, are you ready to play?!
- Uh, coach? That's the funnel cake stand.
- Don't matter, everywhere I go I compete.
- I'll take the biggest prize ever.
- Uhh, looks like you haven't quite earned it yet. Gotta win a few more games.
- Still? What about him?
- I haven't even won anything, but people keep giving me prizes!
- No Ball Pitts today. Maybe next week, maybe not. Go ahead, write our obituary. See if I care.
- Guys, where are you going? It's all patched up. Good as new.
- Try your hand at Trubi-skee ball!
- Are you gonna play?
- A little.
- My turn!
- Why do you still have a baby voice?
- Last year didn't count.
- Not yet.
- What? But that creep on the Browns gets rewarded?
- Hahahaha. Ahahahaha.
- F--k that elf.
- Just gotta hold 'em off now.
- I'm Jalen Hurts. You can like me and still hate Philadelphia.
- Naaah, I need to see more.
- This year there's a lot of pressure, but it's because everyone believes in me!
- I can hang. Ah, where's our defense?
What can I get for all these?
- Something quite special.
[sad music]
- They just never give us running backs what we deserve.
-You wanna split one or do you want your own?
-Ahahah, ahahaha.
-I don't know what that means but I love this kid's motor.
-Hahahahaha.
-Oh, yeah, he's got that dog in him.